>> Jon: WELCOME BACK.
LAST WEEK, WE DID-- LAST WEEK, I
THOUGHT A VERY NICE PIECE ON THE
SHOW ABOUT HOW FOX NEWS WANTED
PEOPLE TO APOLOGIZE FOR RUSHING
TO JUDGMENT ON THE FERGUSON
SHOOTING OF MICHAEL BROWN.
AND SO WE I THINK QUITE CLEVERLY
DREW AN ANALOGY TO THAT
AND THEIR RUSH TO JUDGMENT ON
BENGHAZI, IT WAS REALLY QUITE
DROLL.
NOW WHILE FOX NEVER ADDRESSED
OUR BENGHAZI POINT,
IT APPEARS NOW THEY'RE ASKING
FOR MORE THAN AN APOLOGY.
>> PETE WILLIAMS, TO HIS CREDIT,
GOT THAT BOSTON MARATHON TERROR
REPORTING DEAD ON.
AND THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAILED
HIM AS A HERO FOR GETTING IT
RIGHT, WHICH HE DID.
FOX NEWS GOT THIS CASE RIGHT.
FOX NEWS, NOT JUST ME.
SEAN HANNITY HAD A LOT OF
SEGMENTS, PLUS O'REILLY HAD A
LOT OF SEGMENTS, URGING CAUTION.
WOULD THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA EVER
HAIL THEM AS HEROES LIKE WE
HEARD ABOUT PETE WILLIAMS?
>> Jon: YEAH, WHY DOESN'T FOX
GET AS MUCH CREDIT AS-- WHO'S
PETE WILLIAMS?
( LAUGHTER )
ANYWAY, THE POINT IS, IT WASN'T
THE FIRST TIME THEY GOT IT
RIGHT.
>> I URGED CAUTION IN THE DUKE
COVERAGE, AND IN THE TRAYVON
MARTIN COVERAGE, AND NOW THIS
COVERAGE.
>> Jon: THAT'S THREE TIMES.
THEY GOT IT RIGHT THREE TIMES IN
10 YEARS.
THOSE ARE SOLAR ECLIPSE NUMBERS,
PEOPLE, WHICH I THINK IS WHY
IT'S RECOMMENDED YOU ONLY WATCH
FOX THROUGH A TINY PINHOLE POKED
IN A PIECE OF CARDBOARD.
YOU CAN'T LOOK DIRECTLY AT FOX.
IT WILL INDELIBLY BURN YOUR
SOUL.
WHILE OF COURSE THE WHOLE
RUSH TO JUDGMENT COMPLAINT IS
( BLEEP ), FOX IS NOTHING
BUT A RUSH TO JUDGMENT IN
ALMOST EVERY SITUATION.
OKAY.
YOU'RE THE CAUTION AND SOBER
REFLECTION NETWORK.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT MY FAVORITE PART OF THE
PIECE WAS AFTER 10 MINUTES OF
COMPLAINING THAT NO ONE WOULD
EVER THANK THEM, THIS.
>> IF YOU ARE WAITING FOR THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO SAY NOT ONLY
THAT WE WERE WRONG IN THIS
RACIALLY CHARGED CASE THAT
RESULTED IN SO MUCH VIOLENCE
IN THAT TOWN AND TO CREDIT
FOX NEWS FOR BEING RIGHT,
YOU'RE GOING TO HOLD YOUR
BREATH A LONG TIME.
>> WE DON'T CARE ABOUT THEM.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Jon: RIGHT, YOU DON'T
CARE, IN THE SAME WAY MY MOM
DOESN'T CARE IF I EVER CALL.
( LAUGHTER )
SURE, CALL OR NOT.
I COULD JUST SIT HERE AND DIE.
( LAUGHTER )
BUT THE POINT IS, THE POINT IS
YOU WERE RIGHT,
AND THAT IS NEWSWORTHY
WHEN FOX IS RIGHT.
AND CAUSE FOR CELEBRATION.
SO TO HONOR THAT TIME YOU WERE
RIGHT, WE GOT YOU A FUDGIE THE
WHALE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW WHY, WE THINK
YOU'RE A WHALE OF A NETWORK!
IN THAT WE'VE BEEN CHASING YOU
OUR WHOLE LIVES AND JUST CAN'T
KILL YOU.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL, FOX.
IN HONOR OF THIS SINGULAR
ACHIEVEMENT OF YOU BEING RIGHT,
LIBERAL HOLLYWOOD HAS SOMETHING
THEY'D LIKE TO SAY TO YOU.
HOLLYWOOD.
>> I'M GEORGE LUCUS AND I'M HERE
TO ASSURE YOU THAT I AM ONLY
GOING TO MAKE MOVIES FROM NOW
ON THAT ARE BLINDLY
UNCRITICAL OF AMERICA.
LIKE "THE EMPIRE STRIKES BACK,
JUSTIFIABLY".
"AMERICAN EXCEPTIONALISM
GRAFFITI."
"STAR WARS, THE REAGAN MISSILE
DEFENSE VERSION."
AND "THE CLINTON MENACE."
FOX NEWS, MAY YOU LIVE LONG AND
PROSPER.
WAIT, I DIDN'T WRITE THAT, DID
I?
>> Jon: SORRY. BUT THE TRUTH IS
THIS--
( APPLAUSE )
FOX, WE CAN SEND YOU ALL THE
CONGRATULATORY MESSAGES AND
PRAISE WE CAN MUSTER, BUT IT'S
REALLY JUST GOING TO PALE IN
COMPARISON TO HOW YOUR BIGGEST
FANS FEEL ABOUT YOU, AND
SO WE HAD THEM TAPE SOME
MESSAGES OF CONGRATULATIONS AS
WELL. TAKE A LOOK.
>> ONE NETWORK HAS TRANSFORMED,
REENVISIONED AND REINVENTED THE
WAY NEWS IS DONE.
>> FOX IS THE DOMINANT FORCE IN
BROADCAST NEWS TODAY.
>> WE'RE THE ONLY NETWORK THAT'S
TELLING THE TRUTH RIGHT NOW.
>> IT'S THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN
FEEL GOOD ABOUT YOUR COUNTRY.
>> YOU MIGHT LEARN SOMETHING AS
OPPOSED TO JUST HAVING YOUR
WORLD VIEW REINFORCED.
>> WE GIVE YOU BOTH SIDES.
WE GIVE YOU ALL THE STUFF.
>> WE'RE SIMPLY BETTER THAN THE
OPPOSITION.
>> WE KEEP KICKING THEIR ASS
EVERY DAY IN THE RATINGS.
>> NUMBER ONE.
>> NUMBER ONE, THAT'S US.
>> PROBABLY THE MOST POWERFUL
NEWS AGENCY IN THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
>> WE'RE CERTAINLY COVERING
IT THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU, FOX NEWS.
>> YOU GUY'S, YOU'RE THE BEST.
>> THANK GOD FOR OUTLETS LIKE
FOX NEWS.
>> THANK GOD FOR FOX NEWS.
>> THANK GOD FOX NEWS IS ON IT.
>> THANK GOD.
>> GOD BLESS FOX NEWS.
>> Jon: HE CLEARLY ALREADY
HAS.
THE GREAT THING IS I GET IT NOW.
YOUR NETWORK LAUNCHED IN 1996,
YOU'RE 18 YEARS OLD, AND JUST
LIKE EVERY OTHER 18-YEAR-OLD,
YOU HAVE A MASSIVE EGO AND SPEND
24 HOURS A DAY JERKING YOURSELF
OFF.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.